how often do they successfully like peel
back the layer
to reveal the truth behind the false
domestic allegations because
whenever i've talked to police officers
about them getting calls on that like
the default that they've
like they've been told you just take him
away
he's automatically to blame you know
regardless of what happened and just
throw him in a slammer overnight and
you'll deal with it you know tomorrow
but you have to remove him from the
household if she's scared sort of thing
and it's not like you even have an
opportunity as a guy to have a
conversation with law enforcement or
even offer an opinion like there's a lot
of um there's a lot of videos that i've
seen now that guys have sent to me where
it's like
women have prepared uh for their false
dv
uh charged by running into a wall or
punching themselves in the face you know
like moments before their husband gets
home and she's on a phone it's like he
walks in the door he's like yes yes i'm
very scared he just hit me and he's like
what's going on right right um it
doesn't happen every day obviously but
this is just one example that
has come across my plate a couple times
right i mean that's a problem
uh false uh domestic violence
uh allegations domestic violence is a
real problem
let's let's uh face that but uh
people who stage being hurt or run into
a wall to try to give themselves a black
eye
um and then file a protection from abuse
petition and try to get the guy out that
way um
if they're caught they should be
prosecuted there's they're they're
uh lying under oath uh but it's r
they're rarely prosecuted the case just
gets dismissed
in some jurisdictions including
pennsylvania uh there has to be a
hearing within a certain amount of time
after an initial hearing takes place the
initial hearing is
an ex parte hearing which means only you
the the person making the claim and the
judge is the other side doesn't have a
chance
and i think that that's done because
they want to protect somebody and
they'll err
on the side of maybe not getting it
right right away but within 10 days
there's a final hearing
and both sides are able to put up to
put on their case but to answer your
question i think there was a case where
amber heard and
uh yeah yeah yeah he recorded her
so i tell guys if you're living separate
and apart under the same roof
because a lot of people can't afford to
move out and you're about to file for
divorce
you're not sleeping together but she has
a propensity or you think there's even a
chance
everybody that has a cell phone has a
video recorder
so just pull it out and make sure
that you've got evidence that what she's
trying to do
is wrong and that would that's one
line of defense um you know the courts
try so hard to get these right
um but sometimes people are good liars
and they're actresses and
you know you don't want to you want to
get away from that situation
um and even if you vet people they can
turn into that
so that video recorder can go a long way
i've used it
uh to defend my clients against bald
allegations
yeah um there's a comment here from
abram he says my ex-wife said that i
threatened the family with a gun little
did she know that i'd taken the gun out
of the house two weeks prior she got
caught in a lie
and a false report helped me get full
legal and physical custody of my
daughter
yeah definitely remove your firearms
from your house
you know if you have a gun safe just
bring it over your brother's house